Satoru Gojo is an absolute monster.
Activating his Domain Expansion for just an
instant is enough to knock any human in the
vicinity unconscious.
Any longer than that, and they’ll be robbed
of their sanity, forced to experience every
moment of their lives simultaneously until
they die.
The plans of villains like Kenjaku solely
hinge on getting Gojo out of the way because
he’s the sole force defending the Jujutsu
World.
And if he were on the other side, Jujutsu
High wouldn’t stand a chance against their
star teacher.
After all, he’s a Special Grade Sorcerer
- And a Special Grade is a sorcerer with such
unlimited potential that the limits of their
power are measureless.
Geto could create a massive army of Cursed
Spirits to control.
Yuta could copy endless techniques of other
sorcerers.
But Gojo doesn’t need the help of a single
Cursed Spirit or anyone else: Satoru Gojo
could eliminate all his competition in the
Jujutsu World without even trying.
In Gojo’s past, the Star Plasma Vessel incident
was a massive turning point.
Gojo and Geto were an unstoppable team of
Special Grade sorcerers with the mission of
exorcising curses for Jujutsu High.
That was until they had to go up against a
true monster: Toji Fushiguro AKA Megumi’s
papa.
Even though Gojo’s Six-Eyes gives him essentially
limitless [the screen should say PUN INTENDED]
control over cursed energy, Toji very nearly
killed him and Geto.
Thankfully, Gojo unlocked his ultimate technique:
Hollow Purple and managed to kill his future
star pupil’s dad.
Originally, like Gojo, he’d thought that
sorcerers existed to protect non-sorcerers,
but after this event Geto slowly came to believe
that humans were inferior, taking to calling
them monkeys and working toward sorcerer supremacy.
This led to the Jujutsu Kaisen we know and
love,or at least the Jujutsu Kaisen Zero we
know and love, with the two former besties
Gojo and Geto having to fight against one
another as Gojo upheld the values of Jujutsu
High and sorcerers protecting non-sorcerers
while Geto worked toward normal humans’
eradication.
But what if things went differently?
What if Gojo…the most powerful sorcerer…also
became super evil?
Well, there are a few ways this could shake
out: Four to be exact, so today let’s look
at how JJK would play out differently if its
greatest hero became its most terrifying villain.
Scenario number one: Gojo turns evil and Geto
stays good.
In this first hypothetical, we have a complete
role reversal.
In this one, it’s not Geto who cracks based
on what the two experienced at the hands of
Toji.
Instead, Gojo’s will breaks.
In fact, let’s change it right there: This
time instead of Toji defeating them both and
then getting crushed by Hollow Purple on his
way out, he defeats Gojo and is ultimately
defeated by Geto in the Tombs of the Star
Corridor.
He does still kill Riko, but this time it’s
Geto who kills Toji instead of Gojo.
This results in a huge blow to Gojo’s ego,
but a victory for Geto.
Gojo’s ego is about the size of a planet,
so seeing Geto succeed where he failed would
be hard for him to deal with.
He’s never lost before this, so Gojo has
a mental break as a result, deciding to break
with Jujutsu High instead of Geto, who stays
with them.
However, I just don’t see Gojo developing
the same kind of disgust with normal humans
that Geto does.
He loves rom-coms too much for that kind of
thing.
However, I could see him breaking with Jujutsu
High and going solo to do his own thing.
He’s too powerful to listen to the higher
ups anyway, but instead of leaving like Yuki
did to ride around on a cool motorcycle and
talk to impressionable young men, Gojo would
be flexing his power without limit [PUN INTENDED
AGAIN].
The Jujutsu Higher-Ups would start receiving
reports of cursed energy output all over Japan.
However, whenever their sorcerers would arrive
on the scene, they wouldn’t find Satoru
Gojo.
And they wouldn’t find Cursed Spirits, either
- just their bloodied remains and buildings
reduced to rubble.
When Gojo would go rogue, he would be destroying
cursed spirits with little regard for collateral
damage and causing tons of damage with his
insane powers, even though he wouldn’t be
harboring malice toward humanity in general.
He might, however, target humans he deems
evil such as the Star Religious group specifically.
And in this scenario, Geto would have to be
the one to try and stop him.
There are tons of fan drawings online where
we see what it would look like if Kenjaku
took over Gojo’s body instead of Geto’s…but
that actually doesn’t make sense if you
think about it.
You see, Kenjaku would probably love to have
Gojo’s cursed technique, but it actually
wouldn’t be needed for his plan.
He needs Geto’s cursed technique specifically,
because the maximum uzumaki ability is what
allows him to take Mahito’s Idle Transfiguration
to break Tengen’s barrier during the Culling
Game.
Since Kenjaku needs Geto’s technique specifically,
I think this story still plays out with Evil
Gojo defeating Good Boy Geto, with Geto’s
body then being taken over by Kenjaku.
This time, since Gojo isn’t working for
Jujutsu High, he doesn’t get sealed away
in the Prison Realm.
Instead, he gets to show up and wreak absolute
havoc in the Culling Game, which’ll be great
for Kenjaku’s goal since the Culling Game
needs to release a ton of cursed energy for
Kenjaku’s ritual to work.
In this timeline, Gojo becomes the all time
Culling Game MVP racking up more points than
anybody and taking out ancient sorcerers left
and right.
Of course, we can’t just leave it at that
because I know you want to know what would
happen if Kenjaku DID take over Gojo’s body.
So here’s our second scenario: Geto stays
good, and Gojo becomes Kenjaku’s body instead.
Well, first we’ve got to figure out how
Gojo dies so that Kenjaku is able to take
over his body?
Since the only person - or curse - around
who’s able to be remotely a match for Gojo
is Sukuna, Kenjaku is going to have to get
the King of Curses on his side.
Luckily, Kenjaku’s son happens to be a perfect
vessel for Sukuna.
In this timeline, instead of abandoning the
body of Kaori Itadori, Kenjaku raises Yuji
to be evil.
They collect Sukuna fingers on the DL, with
Kenjaku feeding his son the worst snacks of
all time to unleash Sukuna’s power so that
sonny dearest can eliminate Gojo.
Gojo would be wandering Japan, teleporting
here and there, eliminating curses.
When suddenly Kaori and her beloved four-armed,
twenty finger eating son would show up to
give him the fight of his life.
Suddenly Gojo, despite his limitless cursed
technique would be pinned to the ground.
Kaori Itadori’s reverse cursed technique
would use the power of gravity to pin him
to the ground long enough for Sukuna to slice
and dice him with the Malevolent Shrine.
In this timeline, Geto is still good, so no
one’s coming to Gojo’s rescue.
Kenjaku is able to catch the Evil Gojo off
guard and through a tag team with Kenjaku
and Sukuna, they eliminate the world’s strongest
sorcerer - but barely, because even these
two need all their strength to even actually
hit Gojo.
With him out of the way, there’s no need
to bother with Prison Realms.
Nothing is able to get in the way of Kenjaku’s
evil plans, so he goes ahead and takes Geto’s
body, too and the Culling Game goes off without
a hitch.
But now it’s time to get to the real juicy
stuff.
This time instead of the roles being reversed
with Geto being the good one and Gojo being
evil…Geto stays evil just like in the real
story, but Gojo is joining him in Villain
Land…and let’s just say it’s not going
to go too well for the good guys.
Scenario #3 is that after the Star Plasma
Vessel Incident, it’s not just Geto who
decides to defect from Jujutsu High.
Instead, Gojo also becomes angry at how things
are run and becomes evil right along with
Geto.
With both Gojo and Geto leaving, there’s
no one to vouch for Yuta Okkotsu.
Originally the higher ups of the Jujutsu Society
wanted Yuta killed because his cursed spirit
Rika is insanely powerful.
It’s very possible that this is how things
would play out, but more likely if Gojo and
Geto both exist as threats to the established
order, they’d try to recruit Yuta in order
to use his Special Grade status to defend
against Gojo and Geto’s plans.
Yuta and his classmates would be hard at work
on their studies, when suddenly an army of
Cursed Spirits would descend upon Jujutsu
High.
Panda, Toge, and Maki would put up a courageous
fight, beating down untold numbers of curses.
When it seemed like the onslaught was finally
dying down, they’d look behind them and
see them.
The BFF’s Gojo and Geto, ready to take out
Jujutsu High now that their welcoming party
was over.
Yuta and Rika would fight their hardest, however,
just Geto alone was enough to almost take
Yuta out, so the two together would absolutely
wreck the hero of Jujutsu Kaisen 0.
Along with just about everybody else.
Kenjaku’s role in this story would have
to be much different since he’d be unlikely
to take over either Geto or Gojo’s body.
More likely, Kenjaku would use his abilities
as a master manipulator to join with them
while actually using them for his own purposes,
just like he did with the Disaster Curses.
Either way, an evil team up of Gojo and Geto
is probably going to end up with Sorcerers
coming out of secrecy - they’d pull young
sorcerers away from their connection to the
established Jujutsu Society and likely usher
in an era of Jujutsu supremacy over normal
humans - or monkeys, as Geto would call them.
However, I just can’t see Gojo getting on
board with Geto’s philosophy of hating humans,
which leads us to our 4th scenario, and probaby
the most interesting one:
In this scenario, Gojo and Geto both become
evil, but they’re partnered with one another,
they’re still against each other and walk
along their own villainous paths.
This would introduce a multitude of different
factions that makes the conflict of Jujutsu
Kaisen far more interesting.
While Geto turns evil due to his hatred of
humans, Gojo is going to turn evil just because
he lets his immense power get to his head.
After all, even though Satoru Gojo is by far
the world’s strongest sorcerer, he’s still
used as a pawn by the Jujutsu Society.
Instead of listening to people like the Jujutsu
High principal and Master Tengen, Gojo would
try to ascend to the top of the Jujutsu Society,
reshaping it in his own image.
Instead of listening to the old traditional
rules, he would go his own way, causing a
huge fracture in Jujutsu High.
Whereas a lot of the time, he uses his power
just to prevent the higher ups from killing
young sorcerers with potential like Yuta and
Yuji, he’d recruit them to his own side
as powerful assets.
Surely, other sorcerers who feel outcast by
the major families would join him, too, such
as Maki Zenin who is treated terribly by her
family.
Other sorcerers who are part of the big families
would stay at the sides, so this would lead
to an all out war between the elders of clans
like the Zenin and the Kamo and the younger
sorcerers who side with Gojo.
Sadly, Panda would also remain on the side
of the Old Guard, since the principal of Jujutsu
High created him.
Unlike Geto who wants to destroy humans, Gojo
would still want to protect humanity, but
his newfound vanity and overconfidence would
mean he’d no longer do it from the shadows.
Instead, he would shed the secrecy of Jujutsu
High and let it be known far and wide that
sorcerers were responsible for protecting
humanity from the danger of curses.
He may even take a cue from Yuki and aim to
teach normal humans how to control cursed
energy to prevent the birth of powerful curses
that accumulate from the negative energy released
by normal people.
Yuki would likely be a powerful ally to Gojo
since she left on her own to try to rid the
world of the curses free of the restrictions
of Jujutsu Society’s higher ups.
This was one of the suggestions she gave to
Geto for how to rid the world of curses, which
accidentally led him to the conclusion that
killing all non-sorcerers would be the most
effective way of eliminating curses.
And since that’s Geto’s goal, that means
that he’d still be at odds against Gojo
when it came to the battle for the fate of
JJK’s world.
Meanwhile, Kenjaku is still lurking in the
shadows.
In all likelihood, unable to gather Gojo or
Geto’s bodies, he would probably still try
to ally with the Disaster Curses.
This would lead to an all out war for the
fate of the Jujutsu Society.
On one side, we have Suguru Geto and his followers,
such as Nanaka and Mimiko.
In addition to the followers who could use
cursed energy, he’d also have all of the
curses that he was able to gather using his
cursed technique, leading to an army of cursed
spirits on his side.
Against him, would be Gojo’s group of young
sorcerers including Yuki and Yuta, giving
them three Special Grades on their side.
Also throwing into the ring would be Kenjaku
in Kaori Itadori’s body and the Disaster
Curses, who wish to take advantage of the
conflict to massacre as many sorcerers as
possible and pave the way for curses to take
over the world.
Kenjaku himself would also be taking advantage
of the chaos to try and eliminate Tengen’s
barrier - he’d even possibly try to start
the Culling Game and use the fighting from
this war to activate his ritual.
And finally, we’d have Master Tengen and
the elders of the Three Big Jujutsu Families,
including many of the Gojo family who wouldn’t
appreciate Satoru going his own way.
The battle would be bloody, leaving huge casualties
on every side - but there’s only one way
it ultimately shakes out.
Standing over what was once Jujutsu High,
Gojo’s Six-Eyes would look out over the
carnage.
Principal Yaga and his puppet army would litter
the landscape.
Jogo and the other Disaster Curses would sit
in cinders.
Even Geto and Kenjaku would be dead and gone.
With Gojo’s side having three Special Grade
Sorcerers who totally eclipse lower ranked
sorcerers, Gojo would ultimately win, and
would reshape the Jujutsu World in his own
beautiful blue-eyed image.
Of course, if Kenjaku was able to recruit
Sukuna as well, things might play out differently.
But as it is, Gojo is the world’s strongest
sorcerer and there’s not a lot that can
stop him - after all thanks to his power,
practically nothing can even touch him.
It really begs the question: is he just holding
back in all of his battles so far?
And what would happen if he really let his
full strength fly?
For example, at the Shibuya Incident, what
if he used his full strength against the Disaster
Curses instead of getting trapped in the Prison
Realm: You can find out all about that in
this video